all right here is another great one we
recorded this one in Brooklyn Thank You
New York City for showing up we had two
tours off scheduled this year less is
now tour stops one in Manhattan one in
Brooklyn they both sold out really
quickly and so we added a second
Brooklyn date and that's the one you're
about to hear right now live in front of
a crowd in Brooklyn it was actually our
first time that we'd ever done a tour
stop in Brooklyn then we ended up doing
two so thank you to everyone who came
out
speaking of tour stops Ryan and I are
hitting the road once again you probably
heard that we're coming to Australia and
New Zealand in March of 2018 and the
good news is the response has been so
positive so overwhelming that we had to
add some more dates so we're coming to
Brisbane we're coming to Sydney those
are almost sold out already and we just
announced the date so get your tickets
to those while you can we're also coming
to Oakland and no-burn actually our
Melbourne stop sold out within a few
days and so we added a second Melbourne
stop and then we heard you loud and
clear we're coming to Perth we're coming
to Adelaide tickets to those go on sale
this week over at les is now calm if
you're on our email list you'll be the
first to know actually if you are a
patreon supporter you can already get
tickets because the presale is already
available so if you want to become a
patreon supporter or if you're already a
patreon supporter they're going on
presale right now for all of those new
dates over in Australia and other dates
we're finishing the year here in North
America we're coming to Tennessee in
Washington DC this week those dates are
already sold out so you can't get
tickets to those but you can get tickets
to Georgia and Florida we're coming to
Atlanta and a few tickets left there and
Tampa that one actually sold out but
then we found a bigger theatre so get
your tickets there while you can if
you're interested to see us in Florida
and then we're finishing the year in
Michigan and in Wisconsin we've been
told it's gonna be cold
in the Midwest the Upper Midwest and so
we're coming to bring minimalism to warm
things up a little bit and then we're
starting next year with the charity
event Las Vegas January 14th House of
Blues you can get your tickets now over
lesses now.com for las vegas or any of
the other events I mentioned the Las
Vegas event actually we're donating a
hundred percent of the profits from that
to help out with the well the Las Vegas
Victims Fund there was a terrible
tragedy that happen there recently
with the mass shooting and we want to
find a way to give
I don't think the Ryan and I could
change the world but I do think we can
help whenever we can and so we're going
to give back so if you want to come out
to long holiday weekend you can grab
your tickets les is now dot-com also by
the way I just want to say thanks real
quick before we jump into this episode
I'm back in Missoula Montana for just a
couple days and I was searching around
for a place to record this podcast intro
and there's a coffee shop I come to all
the time I I write and I edit here and I
spent all kinds of time at Zoo town it's
a that's the name of the coffee shop
they have great coffee and who knew they
had a recording studio in their basement
so thank you to zoo town for hooking us
up me and podcast Sean are down here
right now just recording this intro and
so I just want to say thanks to them if
you're in Montana especially if you're
in Missoula and you're looking for an
outstanding cup of coffee zoo town is
the place to go alright and that is it
for now please enjoy this episode of the
minimalists podcast
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your green oh I bet that you'll be fine
without he live from the Bell House
Theatre
my name is Joshua fields Milburn and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalists live in Brooklyn
god I love that New York welcome
although I'm being told it's not just
New York Ryan I'm being told that there
are some people from Connecticut in the
house tonight yeah I'm also being told
that New Jersey is in the house tonight
and I'm also told I don't know if this
is true but it was true the last two
nights we've been we've done three stops
in New York City and man you all keep
showing up this is awesome I'm told
though that there might be one or two
people from the UK or Australia look at
that how awesome is that now I was just
joking about the whole Australian accent
thing earlier during my talk I was
mocking ignorant Midwesterners which I
am one and you know buckeyes yeah Dayton
Ohio born and raised and so yeah we
actually actually coming to to Australia
New Zealand next March les is now calm
if you're listening to this at home
we're in the middle of this this tour we
usually on our podcast we do them in
studio and when I say in studio it's in
a conference room right now and you call
us up and we answer your questions but
there's a microphone back there and so
you can congregate toward that
microphone we'll get to at least five
questions I can promise you that if we
have time for more than I'll see I'll
see what we can do but well we'll start
with five questions and we also we have
a little special treat for you later in
the show as well so someone has broken
the seal already how did what's your
name hey Stephanie we met on the street
earlier you can get closer to that mic
and can I get a little of the audience
Mike in the monitor please so but I'm
wondering when do you enjoy it so
to kind of preface the question
currently I'm going through a lot of
major events in my life I am having a
lot of company come visit me for the
next couple of weeks I am starting a new
job I quit my corporate job to start
into a smaller company in my first
congratulations two weeks office
starting Monday
and then also I'm making the move back
to my life and I'm super excited about
all of these things but it really stood
out to me when my supervisor asked are
you excited about your new job you
seemed a lot more excited to move up
here and take a lateral move within Bank
of America than you are about a new
smaller company where you're making more
money and just going to be happier
overall and so I'm wondering where do
you take the pause in your life and
actually enjoy all those good things
because I'm sure there's several people
that wish all these good things are
happening to them and they're all
choices that I'm making for myself so I
should be excited and not internally
like panicking and being really nervous
about all of these good things but at
the moment I'm just gonna rest and panic
and stress so when do you actually take
that step back and enjoy all of the
quote unquote good things that are
happening to you sure I I think a few
things here you first off you might not
be as nervous as you think you might
actually be excited and you're mistaking
one for the other I think quite often
that happens to us because they have
both emotions they're on both sides of
the spectrum right you have this
negative emotion nervous or anxiety I
could tell you before we come out on
stage often I'll be I'll feel really
nervous and like we're going to talk to
however many people are in the audience
that night and my palms are sweating my
heart starts racing and I'm mouth starts
to go a little bit dry and and I'm
getting jittery kind of feel those
butterflies and then I'm like oh my god
Ryan I'm so nervous right now and he'll
be like he'll be like I'm not I'm
excited my but my heart's racing and my
mouth is dry and
I'm just I've got these these excited
jitters and I'm like oh yeah maybe I'm
just excited or maybe maybe they're the
same thing and and I think we have to
think about that now here's the other
thing you you mentioned well you know
what I am moving toward I'm moving
toward this lifestyle that a lot of
other people might envy or want or
whatever this move this change that I'm
making and maybe I'm supposed to enjoy
it you're not supposed to do anything
just because someone else would enjoy
what you're about to do doesn't mean
that it's the right move for you and
maybe what you're feeling right now is
in outside of the nervous thing maybe
it's a sign to say well wait a minute
maybe this isn't the right move for me
and and you have to get really clear on
what you want your outcome to be
and in this case and if you don't know
what you want your outcome to be and
more much more important why do you want
that outcome and do you want that
outcome because it's the next logical
step I can tell you I I spent what 12
years climbing the corporate ladder
navigating each logical step and here's
the terrifying part about that when I
got to age 30 and I look down and I'm
like oh it's too far for me to jump back
down I might as well keep climbing that
was my first instinct because well it's
too late for me to turn around a gotten
this far I might as well keep going here
was the problem though I started to see
the guys that I emulated the guys who I
wanted to be like I aspired to live like
these guys the CEO CFO CEO OHS and
something they were bad people but the
closer I got to them I started to notice
they were miserable some of them were on
you know the third marriage and their
second heart attack and I realized that
if I worked my butt off for the next 15
or 20 years maybe I could be just like
them and that didn't seem like the path
that I wanted to go down and so I
decided to jump off that ladder and man
that was terrifying but continuing to a
sin seemed a bit more terrifying
to me can I ask you um like what makes
you feel nervous like what what kind of
thoughts go through your I'm just
curious being a contributor to my new
team successfully I'm worried about that
and then I haven't had a roommate since
college either I'm very introverted I'm
really good with people when I have my
alone time as well but coming home I
never had the desire to come home and
chat about my day with someone I text my
friends about that and so I don't know
that all of the things that come up with
so I'm sorry is this the roommate is it
a roommate or is this a significant
other okay well the good news is is you
don't know your roommate anything except
for half of the rent and utilities I
think you definitely don't want to talk
about your day at the end of the day so
it's it's change is what is making you
nervous and the word that stuck out to
me was you're scared of failure which
that is certainly something that we all
I think get nervous about when a change
is happening like it like there's a
change happening and it might not be a
better change um I got good news and bad
news for you I'll give the bad news
first you're gonna fail at some point in
your life between now and the end of it
all of us here will fail at some point
between now and the end of our lives and
maybe that's actually maybe I got good
news and good news because knowing that
and accepting that and embracing the
fact that yeah you're not gonna be
perfect and there are gonna be some
things that you're probably gonna have
to work out might actually help you
prepare a little bit more in fact I
think anxiety or excitement I think both
are a way to prepare your
for what's to come so accept the fact
that yeah it's it's not gonna be perfect
but if you are learning from those
failures and you're putting your best
foot forward if you can go home at the
end of your work day and and look in the
mirror and say you know what I did
everything I could
I'm doing something that elicits to my
values and beliefs and but you know
something kind of messed up it's okay to
feel good go to sleep wake up and then
learn from that the next day and then
the other the other good news is is that
it's gonna be okay I promise yeah I mean
there are there are people who you know
I like I'll walk down the street and
I'll see someone homeless and I'm like
oh man like I just feel so bad for where
I'm like man Ryan how many decisions are
you away from being homeless and I've
had this conversation with Josh before
and Josh is like dude you will never be
homeless it's because you make really
good decisions and you have learned from
your failures and it would really take
an extreme an extreme case mental
illness you know severe drug at a
something that would really really put
you in that place but Ryan that chances
of you getting there are very slim and I
guess that's that's what I want to tell
you is go for it go for it and put your
best foot forward and I promise you it's
going to be it you're not going to be
homeless
I swear to God yeah I think it's
important to ask that to ask a similar
question there because I mean in it
obviously homelessness is a huge huge
problem and and it's it's something that
we need to do a better job addressing
societally and also from a government
perspective but being able to contribute
in some way and there are ways where
people who were you know the intern like
with what's going on in Houston right
now I mean there's huge in fact a couple
nights ago in Philadelphia I was I
talked about this on the bonus podcast
we did we recorded yesterday but since
we're doing a normal pot Castle I feel
good about talking about again we had a
couple come up to us you know my talk I
talked about how you could rent a
dumpster and throw all your [ __ ] in it
and still be miserable we had a couple
in Philadelphia come up and say you know
what um we didn't listen to that advice
we just got a dumpster and started
putting a lot of our stuff in it and we
were a bit too zealous because there was
a dumpster fire in our entire house
caught on fire and so our whole house
burned down as we were minimizing and
she looked me dead in the eyes and she
said I want to thank you because I think
if that would have happened before I
would have thought about what things can
I run into my house and grab but the
only thing I thought about was are my
children safe because as long as my
children are safe everything's going to
be okay and so I like to flip that on
its head sometimes sometimes I'll ask
myself we hear this question all the
time like what's the worst that could
happen well sometimes the answer is some
really terrible [ __ ] could happen what's
the worse that happen do you drive 140
miles an hour down the highway
well you might die right what's the
worst thing happen if you sleep around
have unprotected sex with hundreds of
people well I think we know
and and and so I the the truth is if
we're not being safe and really bad
decisions that we're making yeah some
bad [ __ ] can happen but I also like to
ask the other question of the time is
well I might find another job okay was
the sound that bad or you know the the
worst that can happen is usually not
that bad at all but the other side is
when I make a change in my life what's
the best that can happen and NSR
thinking about all the possibilities and
that's when change doesn't make me
nervous that's when change makes me
excited thanks for your question howdy
what's your name from Mexico City wagons
wow thanks for coming out in this my
best friend's father died and then the
quakes and it's difficult being here but
well then I will have to go into that
you know so I didn't do it
many situations with your pal he was
like crap yes so sometimes our values
are opposing values is that what you're
saying relationship with your friends or
your family that is so free right now
yeah yeah so so where do you start what
are the most important values if you
feel like your values have collapsed or
that your priorities are out of order or
you feel like you're not living up to
what your values are sometimes because
of a situation that's outside of your
control right yeah so I give you a
personal example I you know so Ryan and
I on our first book is a book called
minimalism live a meaningful life we
wrote about the five foundational values
or health relationships passion or
creativity growth and contribution and
and I think all five of these are are
perspectival meaning my idea of health
is going to be different from Ryan's
it's gonna be different from your idea I
think we can agree on some fundamental
principles but ultimately my version of
health is going to look different
necessarily and I've had
of health problems over the last two
years fact about a year ago next month
we had to we stopped doing the podcast
altogether there was a point where I
updated my will because I thought I was
dying a year ago and I'm like I might as
well get ready for this like I don't
know where it's going but I got to a
point where I had really bad memory loss
like short-term memory loss in
particular and I realized that even
though I was focused on my health I will
it was the thing I needed to focus on
more than anything else more than my
creativity more than contributing beyond
myself even though those that's very
important to me
more than growing I needed to you know
this value had sort of been swept out
from underneath me and I needed to do my
best not to be perfect but I didn't want
perfect to be the enemy of ideal and I
needed to get closer to what my ideal
was and and that's what that's what I'm
continuing to do right now I have
mercury poisoning it's really awful I
have a messed up microbiome and my gut
and I have done a lot to repair that
over the last year and I continue to
focus on my health but I got to a point
where I felt good enough I had improved
my health health enough over those five
or six months that I decided okay now we
can actually focus on on going out doing
this tour and and doing a few other
creative things but not overload my
health don't forsake my values in order
to to try to tackle other values
[Applause]
howdy hi my name is Monique
hey Monique were you from my hometown ha
Nebraska welcome thank you the hell of a
drive good so my question is I wrote
mine down well just backstory my husband
and I felt like we were living the
quintessential American dream and then
we so sorry we watched your documentary
over the summer and then we woke up and
so you know got to donating and getting
rid of things and then you realize
you're left with this massive house
that's empty yeah so you know notably
there are less boxes coming to the house
which is great but at the same time my
question is how does minimalism become
more contagious especially when it comes
to real estate and development and then
even beyond that the community that
you're in how does it become bigger than
just this is the information I know I'm
stuck in this big house how does it go
forward with real estate community and a
bigger map yeah I think the way ideas
become contagious is well it's the whole
tagline for Ted ready they say ideas
worth spreading
right and what makes someone spread
something Ryan talked about this a
little bit in his talk toward the end
when he talked about adding value I
think it's a natural human instinct to
want to add value to other people's
lives and you know we're on social media
and for the Twitter's and all that stuff
but our most powerful social media
platform is that email forward button
because if you forward something to
people you really care about not just
your tweet it or share it on Facebook
those things can help they can help
expand the message you know but those
platforms tend to be a bit noisier then
if I know Monique and if she forwards me
something I'm going to actually look at
hey Josh I really thought you would like
this documentary I really thought you'd
like this podcast I really thought you'd
like this book or this TV show or
whatever maybe if I know you personally
or Ryan sends me something personally I
mean yeah it's like my friends probably
it's so tired of how often I send out
Seth Godin essays to them but usually
it's when it resonates with a with a
person individual me I think this one
thing will resonate with you I send some
of my partner Beck's who's here tonight
somewhere she's hiding in the shadows
but um I sent her a podcast I was
finding value in the other day but she
also knows I don't send her something
just like well I kind of like this maybe
you should check it out I'll say hey I
think you'll really find value in this
podcast episode especially around the
38th minute mark and and when we do that
and we target the people closest to us
we we do that because we care about them
and we find value in something in hopes
that maybe they'll find a similar amount
of value in that thing and then of
course that happens with ideas as well
when you start to see things like in our
documentary you you saw Graham Hill in
there he's in New York City and in
Manhattan and he has that four hundred
and what ten square foot foreign 30
square foot apartment that is you can
sleep seven it has a movie theater in it
it you can have dinner for 12 there's
also a home office there and a bathroom
and a shower and everything else and
like 410 square feet and that's because
it's a very I mean it's the most
deliberate use of space
that I have ever seen probably right
because it's so multifunctional and so
you you see an idea like that and most
of us can't afford an apartment like
that in in Manhattan but it's not that
what he's trying to share he's sharing
the idea of shared resources shared
space shared community within the the
proximity of other people who have
similar ideas they may not be
like-minded people but they're
open-minded people and if we share those
ideas with other open-minded people
that's how they spread I would love if
everyone became a minimalist and a lot
of people are like well if that happened
the economy would tanked
well minimalists they still buy stuff
it's just not this endless cycle of
buying something new getting rid of the
old and then buying the new thing if
months later yeah it would be great if
this would again like reach every single
person and move everyone you know it
when it comes down to it like Josh and I
we are out telling our stories we are
and we have you know two different
stories two different recipes and we're
not really proselytizing we're not
trying to convert anyone you can't even
do that by definition like you can't
convert anyone to a minimalist the
reason why Josh and I do this is in
hopes that maybe there are a few
ingredients that y'all can take home and
apply to your own life to help you live
more meaningful lives you know it like
the packing party for example I'm sure
most of you were like that's freaking
crazy I've got six kids at home I would
never do that and you're right I would
agree with you that would be pretty
crazy for a family of six or eight or
whatever um even you know even a family
3 whatever but there I know there I know
there are people out there who were like
yeah that packing party thing that is
awesome so you know for Josh and I we
will continue to do this you know as
long as y'all keep showing up we'll keep
showing up alright before before we move
on we'll just pause for one second if
you're listening to this at home and you
have a comment or a tip for anyone who
asked a question today or about any of
our monitoring's on the stage here you
can you call up leave us a voicemail for
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine or send a voice memo right from
your phone to podcast at the minimalists
comm we will air our favorite comments
and tips on a future episode and really
I'd say it's my favorite part of the
show it's very end of the show we pepper
in a handful of listener comments and
tips because I get to learn so much from
other people it's one of the reasons
we're on the road we get to listen and
and see people face to face which is so
much better than just being on the phone
but also when people call Lynn I get
like these little practical tips that a
sometimes I just use for myself but B it
makes my answers sound more smart when
we're on the road
so yeah please please listen at the end
there you'll get some some practical
comments and tips from from our
listeners Ryan do you know what time it
is it is time for our hashtag ask the
minimalists lightning around where well
we usually answer questions from social
media but that would be weirder if we
were on our phones up here on stage
indeed we're on Twitter and Instagram
and Facebook yeah Facebook at the
minimalists Jessica's here she runs all
the social media stuff yeah ladies and
gentlemen Jessica Williams give her a
round of applause what's really nice
about that is she helps curate some of
the articles and things that we share
Ryan and I still have the opportunity to
interact with everyone online and
respond to comments when we want to and
stuff like that but she curates a lot of
things that we hope will add value to
your lives on those platforms but also
allows us to to interact with you as
well and so during this segment this
will Ryan I usually try to answer your
question with a short shareable less
than 140 character response something
tweetable we call the minimal Maxim's by
the way we just started a website called
minimal Maxim's comm and it has just
hundreds if not over a thousand of of
our quotes at this point from the
podcasts and books and other stuff and
the problem is we don't have a week to
craft an answer for you so we'll Mandar
up here a little bit ramble on until we
can come up with a pithy answer to to
satisfy you that you all can share a
tweet by the way jest tends to live
tweet this whole event from our account
if did you look at that hashtag les is
now which is the name of the tour you
can also share your photos and quotes
from the night will repost some of our
favorites with hashtag glasses now howdy
what's your name joy do you need to have
the right to say healthcare for you to
think well I don't need to climb the
corporate ladder because I don't need to
have a lot of savings
I have a healthcare issue or do you need
to believe that there's a right or an
ability to ask to say education down the
road in the event that you want to for
your children for example to give them a
better life so that you don't you don't
you know abandon their future in your
pursuit of minimalism how do you think
about what's the baseline that's needed
I think my pithy answer is something
like minimalism is apolitical and that's
been the really nice thing for me in and
I'd say for me Ryan we have we've just
different personalities
I'm an INTJ he's an ENFP for those of
you who are familiar with rotten
myers-briggs and which we're like exact
opposites like yin and yang but we also
have we have even though we have
different personalities we have
different beliefs interests desires you
know one of us is always on time one of
us isn't and and also we have different
religious beliefs we have different
political beliefs we voted for two
different people in the last election
there are more than two people to vote
for just so you know
and and and that's been the really nice
thing for me so when it comes to
discussing rights I think we start to
get into the the political realm and I
don't mean political in the original
sense of the world it word if if you go
back and look at the Latin root of the
word politics it means the community or
the art and science of how the people
govern themselves and that's a whole
different discussion than well how we
talk about politics today with politics
in America we talk about red and blue
and my team versus your team my tribe
versus your tribe and the nice thing
about minimalism is it's a different
type of tribe it's almost opting out of
that that kind of sort of identity where
look at me I've put on this and
therefore I have to disassociate from
the other team I know minimalists who
voted for everyone who you could have
possibly voted for in that last election
I know people who are conservative
liberal and and they have the same
values they happen to have different
beliefs which means they get there via
different paths and so minimalism is a
political and that's the good news was
that the Pitney one the lesson is enough
yeah my pet the answer I won't ramble
I'll just give it to you a minimalist
needs to believe and only themselves
what's that for certainly apply that to
myself but to the extent affects others
we didn't choose necessarily the path
and that I would have to forsake some of
their comforts in my pursuit minimalism
you know how does one reconcile those
yes so what I would say is just
reiterating to believe in yourself that
you can absolutely have a simple
lifestyle a meaningful life with your
family you believe that you can provide
for them if that's if that's what you
have to do you have to go to believe
that you can in order in order for the
to order for that to happen and you know
in the very beginning when I'm like hey
imagine in a life a year from now here
so now and I talked about how you know
what you're picturing isn't a a perfect
life and it certainly isn't an easy life
but a but a simple one and that is in in
our talk very deliberately because oft
it's too often we confuse simple with
easy and easy is not I'm sorry simple
easy as easy but simple is not easy so I
don't want to like I don't want you to I
don't want to just you know blow your
question off and say well just believe
in yourself see you later because
because that that sounds easy I want to
be very clear that believing in yourself
and forming a meaningful life not just
for you but for your family also it is
gonna be a lot of work it isn't going to
be easy but I promise you that if you
continue to work at it asking the right
questions making sure that your your
short term actions align with your long
term values and beliefs working towards
that plan that you can see off in the
distance like I promise you it will
eventually it will eventually work it
may not be perfect but you know don't
let perfect be the enemy of ideal thank
you thank you thank you
we're gonna do one more lightning round
question and then we'll do a bonus round
question here in a moment
howdy what's your name hey Hannah where
you from originally Austin Texas
welcome thank you I actually moved here
a month ago with minimalist or broke but
yes
[Laughter]
so my question is a little bit of
backstory about a year ago I went on a
month and a half long 7,000 mile
motorcycle road trip and somebody what
kind of hug you got I have a KLR 650
before they redid the engine nice is
that a cool bike Sean Sean Sean
Steamboat Sean's the motorcycle rider so
with with that trip to saddlebags in a
backpack and it was incredible as one of
the best life decisions I've ever made
but returning to the real world
I was actually relating a lot more with
people who had been deployed which is a
weird mentality to like join as a
civilian but going like with y'all's
journey into minimalism I'm wondering
what brought you back to the real world
or what stopped you from just like going
full hermit and just being like I am
never returning to this consumer society
because I remember like this moment very
strongly in Idaho and being like I could
just leave I could just stay on the bike
and never come back and it would be
fantastic and then I did come back
because the money ran out but I'm
wondering why you guys came back my
Pythian sir is something like sometimes
we have to remove ourselves from the
chaos so we can re-enter more
deliberately and I remember when Ryan
and I first moved out to Montana as five
years ago we moved to this cabin and
middle of nowhere it was like super
cheap we found on Craigslist it was
already furnished by furnish I mean it
had a couch and two beds and we started
writing a book and we really did sort of
remove ourselves from that and then we
eventually rejected ourselves into
normal life and I think minimalism is
the way that'll it minim minimalism for
me has been the middle ground it's not
being an ascetic or a monk although we
had a monk come up to one of our events
recently he just came there to shame us
what are you doing he walked up to the
mic and he said so you telling me I have
to become a monk to be a minimalist and
no I mean that's the whole point I mean
that yeah the the the monks or ascetics
or even people who are really in the
stoicism they they will deprive
themselves for much longer periods of
time than I find necessary and for me
minimalism wasn't about that it was
about living in a modern-day world with
the newest problems I mean I think this
this solution we call minimalism now
it's several thousand years old I had to
break it to you like we didn't invent
this it's old solutions to a new problem
and that new problem is rampant
consumerism and and we're using ancient
wisdom to face them a a pretty complex
problem and and make that complex a bit
more simple I have a pet the answer but
I'm gonna preface it a little bit um you
know are we met with our tour booking
agent he came to our event last night in
Manhattan and we were talking about the
podcast and I was telling them how you
know like it feels really weird to say
but like we have one of the biggest
podcasts in the world like that feels
really really weird to say and he was
like you guys aren't doing
advertisements and I'm like I'm like no
man
Oh Ryan you could use a nice shave right
now I could have you thought about has
anyone get razor rash once the last time
you had a comfortable night's sleep I'm
thinking for just like maybe a doll or a
week you could have razors delivered
right to your door and you know I'm
having this conversation with them and I
was joking around and I'm like yeah you
know I talked to Melbourne about selling
out but I just can't get him on board
and you know I started I'd have you know
of course I've thought about this you
know at some point during this whole
journey and I'm like man you know like
Dave Ramsey he talks about you know if
you can save up 3 million bucks this is
the perfect amount because you can live
off the interest and the interest gives
you so much to live a comfortable life
so you know I'm like okay well maybe
it's not six figures maybe maybe it's
three million dollars but okay so let's
say let's say that you know Josh and I I
talked him into it we started selling
razors or mattresses or whatever on our
podcasts and I can make three million
dollars and I could put all that in the
bank then I would be the king of who
gives a [ __ ] and that's a problem with
me so you know really really broke or
really really poor neither of those
situations sounds great to me so here's
my pithy answer in order to live a
meaningful life you have to also
contribute meaningful creations Jess
you're going to edit that a little bit
thank you thanks a lot we'll move on to
the last question in a moment but first
I got something special for you that
we're gonna move on to our added value
portion of the show and this is usually
a Ryan and I talk about something that
has added value to our lives recently
and we have a we've been doing a local
flair while we're out on the road but
this one is like a weird kind of local
right there is one possession that has
added more value to my life over the
last seven years than any other
possession and I'm pretty deliberate
about the things that I bring into my
life but also the things that I hold on
to and in our documentary there was a
woman named Juliet Shore and she said
the problem isn't that were too
materialistic the problem is that were
not material enough and our materialist
enough meaning we don't often care about
the things we bring into our lives and
we treat a lot of the things like
they're disposable and there's two
problems with that for costly just
dispose everything we're just we're
wasting a lot of money and and its
impact on the environment and all the
problems that come along with that but
then also we usually don't even get rid
of the disposable things we dispose of
it in our addicts closets based
basements spare bedrooms that become
storage rooms and then of course the
twenty two billion dollar storage
industry
you know that's where we're keeping all
of these disposable things as opposed to
bringing things into our life that will
last a long time and had a lot of value
and well when our documentary came out
something really pissed me off
I got over a thousand messages via
various platforms and email and
everywhere else people ask me hey really
loved your documentary where did you get
that bag that's in the documentary where
can i buy that bag and I'm like oh
that's what you got from the documentary
it's a [ __ ] advertisement for a bag
and like it was an I didn't even really
pay attention that the bag was in there
we were at a hotel room and I was like
unpacking and and so it's I used this
bag for the last seven years and people
started asking me and every time I in
fact at one point I had this like auto
text response because I so they'd asked
so many times unfortunately the the the
guy who started who made the bag made it
as like an art project and made only 300
of them and stopped making it in 2012
and and good luck with your search
thinkers what the the message basically
said and I felt bad because that was the
message they got all the documentary but
then also like you know what I have to
say like I have to turn all these people
down I can't even point them in the
right direction and it's true this thing
has added immense value to my life over
the last six or seven years and the
hundreds of cities that we've gone to
and so eventually the guy who made it
his name was Malcolm Phan ta and he he
reached out to me eventually and we'd
never talked before and he said hey I'm
starting to get messages about this bag
I don't know how because I don't know
how people know you didn't talk about it
it's not like in the credits of the film
or anything so I imagine you're getting
a lot of messages - have you ever
thought about maybe bringing that bag
back out and I'm like what no we're the
minimalists I can't imagine putting our
name on a physical good and he's like
what do you not get value from the bag
I'm like yeah it's the best thing I've
ever owned he's like what no serious I'm
like no seriously it's the best and
worst thing I've ever owned it's the
worst thing because pee all these people
keep asking me about it and it's the
best thing because I use it more than
any other one item and he's like well
this sounds like something you get a lot
of value from I'm like yeah you're right
hey would you ever consider partnering
up on on bringing this bag back out and
I'm like man I don't know like we've
never put our name on a physical good
before and and then he said well how
about we just don't put any logos on the
bag then and I said yeah I don't know
let's talk more about and we got to
talking more and more about it and we
had to make sure our values lined up and
you know the processes were sustainable
and everything else and and then he was
just as passionate about the project as
we were because for me money is is never
is never the primary driver for doing
what we do now don't get me wrong I'm
not allergic to money I like money just
fine it's a great resource but I don't
want it to drive what my behaviors are
it's the reason we don't do
advertisements on the podcast
well that because advertisement
they suck worse than that come on
we don't do pirate eyes on the podcast
because advertisements you're damn right
they do and so we decided to partner up
and and try to do like a a crowdfunding
campaign to see if other people were
interested in in the bank which were
actually gonna wait to put this episode
out until that that crowdfunding thing
starts here's the thing that the cavy
I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna pull
Malcolm out here in a second we could
talk about it you probably don't need
another bag and so you probably don't
want to buy it and I don't want to tempt
you to buy a bag the thing that the
reason that we're bringing this the
helping Malcolm bring this back out and
really given feedback because I've used
on the road for the last six years is
it's something that I've that I've found
immense value and I know some other
people would as well but if you don't
need a bag please don't feel compelled
to buy one you will be just fine without
it
ladies and gentlemen Malcolm Phan ta
yeah I should say I should say
Brooklyn's own Malcolm Phan ta yeah
[Applause]
all right so so Malcolm the the first
thing is we want to make this bag as
cheaply as possible so what's the
cheapest sweatshop we can make this at
our own office right now but but now
we're but like you guys we don't like to
cut any corners and so it's like we
actually cause a lot of people that we
work with a lot of stress yeah we just
we demand we demand with the design of
the bag we're designing it we demand
like everything be perfect but then also
with their suppliers we're not we're not
actually making the bag ourselves we
were working with a with factory in Asia
but we're very very particular with them
too and we have partners there that are
meeting with the factory regularly and
and causing them a lot of headaches but
the results gonna be worth it
so yeah I know one thing that you're
passionate about is zero plastic
whatsoever right because clearly we have
a huge plastic problem in general so in
in manufacturing and also packaging and
it becomes an afterthought whenever you
buy a new a new thing that you want or
need there's just this overwhelming
plethora of plastic wrapping and you've
decided to do something unique and sort
of make this bag by the way it's called
packed bags PA Katie I wish I would've
I'm traveling with it right now but it's
back in my plush Hampton Inn hotel room
and you know it's I should have brought
it but if you want to see it use just
packed bags calm ph k tea bags calm VI
kt bags dot-com um and i'm gonna spell
it wrong anyway you decided to turn this
packed bags experiment into a bit of a
what would you call a case study okay
study this projects got a lot of stuff
wrapped up into it which makes it a it's
a lot of fun but most i'm into
environmental stuff i do spend my free
time most of my free time outdoors and
before these guys went and used our bag
in in a movie threw everything off
course
seriously it was totally a total
accident a year ago the movie when i
netflix so it last november last
december yeah yeah a year ago if some if
anyone asked me if i was gonna get back
in into a bag business of in like no
hell no been there done that and then
and then the movie came out and I think
we actually connected like in I don't
know shortly after the new year maybe
February or something but I was actually
working on I'm working on new venture to
reduce the amount of plastic waste that
makes it into our oceans and I was
totally set on doing this so in the
beginning actually I actually it's funny
to hear you say that about the copy and
paste response about the bag so I have
my own - uh-huh
people started asking me at first people
the bag has actually sold five or six
years ago if they stopped selling it and
and over the years a few people have
found different videos on YouTube and
stuff and asked me about it but then
suddenly last year it just started
picking up what's going on here so I
created that auto response and like copy
a base sorry there are none available
and people asked can I get it and use
somewhere like I don't know where I
don't know where you can do that either
but I was totally set on I was doing
this because I was totally focused on
working on this new environmental
venture to try and fight plastic waste
that makes it into our oceans so I
started looking at this project oh maybe
there's there's too much to ignore here
and they work with these guys you know
it'll be fun and you know it'll free up
my time to do some other things so we
came up with a way to
to continue doing the plastic fight
plastic fighting problem project while
doing this project so we're going to do
is we're gonna use the couple facts here
single-use plastic makes up like over
thirty percent of all the of plastic
produced in the world but it makes up
over seventy percent of the plastic that
makes it into the natural environment
and to the oceans so it's like it's all
the plastic that is um it's comes
wrapped around the products that we all
you know the products that we do buy you
know you get by something you you take
it out of the box and before you get to
your actual product you've got five
different pieces of plastic sitting
there and that's part of the problem
it's the stuff that we don't even think
about that manufacturers don't think
about they just you know they make they
design their product and they wanted to
get to the end user so what we're doing
is using the bag as a case study to
prove to show how you can package a
product safely and it'll it'll be
delivered in good shape to the to the
end user without any plastic and we're
gonna use it so we'll highlight that
they'll be will direct people once they
if they received this product so did you
notice I didn't have any plastic
packaging and they can go to a site to
see what packed packed bags and other
companies are doing - yeah you know yeah
that is awesome
thank you
I was gonna say another thing that
excites me about this bag is the
durability uh do you want to talk to
that a little bit so here's the thing
like it's hard for me to describe the
thing because it it defies
categorization it is a duffle bag
messenger bag suitcase and there's none
of these things at the same time it it's
almost I think with the way I originally
described the people who asked me about
about the bag was somehow Malcolm made a
deal with the devil to defy physics
because I could fit more stuff in this
small bag then I could into a big
suitcase that I had and those suitcases
always had there were like crazy bulky
and then I started looking for other
bags and weren't bulky like that but
they always had like 73 pockets on them
none of which I knew what to do anything
with and so I figured out really really
quickly like as soon as I got this like
you did something special here and I'm
like I really hope I can beat this up
because I'm going to be taking on the
road and man I have ya know the reason
why I bring up the durability is um one
of my favorite companies is Patagonia
because they go out another way to make
great products products that are gonna
last in fact they're advertised like
what was her effort I spent last year
maybe was a year before it was like hey
here's our new jacket but you probably
don't need to buy this jacket they
encourage people to buy their clothes
used to prepare the clothes when they
get broken but if they have a van that
goes around the country and and repairs
their their old clothes welcome the
module or wherever sometimes it they'll
repair clothes and so even repair other
companies clothes if you bring it in if
they think that it's repairable and I
think the the way they can do that is
because their clothes are and and things
are so durable that they don't have to
repair them nearly as often as they
would
you know the fast fashion kind of places
now there's on the durability thing this
whole this whole project has actually
been it's very unique I'm an industrial
designer and I've designed all types of
products before doing doing the bag and
but there's typical process to it you
make your prototypes you test them you
know you've tested to see if they're if
they're durable enough everything seems
like it's gonna be tough what ended up
being oh happy accident with this
project is the fact that we stopped
producing this bag for five years yet
people that had the bags like these guys
actually Joshua we're just we're still
be using its thing and and then we know
that we're gonna bring it back it made
that period which we thought was just
the end of producing those bags it
turned it into like a five year
prototyping phase and so we really got
so getting these bags back and getting
you know seeing people's bags that that
have them that have just been you know
traveling around the world with them you
get to see the things that did wear out
and like so this guy said it is a
durable bag it's very it's very durable
but neva tably there's certain things
that break oh yeah I broke some [ __ ] on
this bag and it is cobbled together at
this point and that's like the lessons
we learned like hey you know what it in
Malcolm I think the reason he really
went apart of it he's like hey can you
just like show me all the [ __ ] that you
broke on this bag like the zippers like
there were like the little pull tabs and
then like what are other things that you
would change to make it even make it the
same bag but also make it a little bit
better so that it continues to function
well beyond the six or seven years that
I've had it now
DIY master on his resume somewhere too
because it's one of his skills he showed
me his bag he's like oh yeah this broken
this is what I did to fix it and I did
this and most of the hacks look decent
most of them but so now getting these
bags back so this it's been a cool
opportunity to to create a new updated
version and one of the things these guys
the guys told me
like when those discussions back and
forth about whether or not we were gonna
collaborate was that if you're gonna do
this is like I don't want you to we
don't want you to change much because
the thing is nearly perfect and that
kind of goes against everything that the
designers are taught as a designer you
just want to tear everything apart start
over again I can do this better but it's
a cool set of constraints and you know
we realize we do have a bag that is
nearly perfect but there's always
something that can be changed so we
looked at bags like the ones that these
guys carried and Josh is what it broken
on his and then let's try to make that
even stronger let's make it let's you
know we can reach so that differently
you know so that you know this bag is
still going strong after five years
let's make you know this next one should
be and just as good a shape after ten
years or more and so that you know if
you gonna you know it's not it's not a
cheap bag it's not cheap to make stuff
like that but if you do choose this bag
and you know spend money on it it should
last you
yeah and that was the other thing to
make sure it's not crazy expensive
either because that you're the markup
from from manufacturing to this it to
the retail price well will not end up
being really expensive but but also a
large chunk of some of the profits we're
gonna go back into the the organization
the the C hive organization that Malcolm
is working with to help fight with the
plastic in the oceans as well so I think
the nice thing is we can also do
something good with a with a
manufacturer good that is deliberate and
all that said before I wrap this up here
you probably don't need another bag and
so you don't have to buy it if you're
interested in finding more about the bag
it's packed bags calm phk tea bags calm
it's on all the social media as you can
see pictures and and all that fun stuff
as well Malcolm thank you for doing what
you do thank you for being thanks so
much I really appreciate you guys
[Applause]
all right y'all quick interruption if
you want to listen to our bonus episode
this week as well as all of our past
bonus episodes head on over to the
minimalists comm and click donate at the
top of our website
each week we publish the minimalists
private podcast exclusively for our
patreon supporters this private podcast
shows up in your normal podcast feed
like Apple podcasts overcast Google Play
or whatever podcast app you use and it
shows up right next to our normal weekly
podcast you know the one you're
listening to right now and being a
patreon supporter also gets you first
access to the best tickets to all of our
live events as well as access to our
monthly private livestream video which
is called ask the minimalists anything
it's worth noting that none of this
money goes to me or to Ryan instead
we're using your contributions to build
a new podcast in film studio in Los
Angeles so that we can create more
meaningful audio and video creations if
you already support this podcast thank
you I know that $2 often doesn't sound
like a lot of money I mean it's less
than a cup of coffee but it is your
support that keeps this podcast 100%
advertisement free because
advertisements suck and if we can just
get 2% of our audience to support this
show then we'll have enough funds to
produce some amazing new creations your
support is truly appreciated alright
y'all back to the regular show yeah well
wrap it up really quick Sean I'm sure
you can figure out how to add all of
that
ladies and gentlemen podcast Sean hiding
in the shadows
[Applause]
well I just want to thank a few people
before before we get out of here
I'm back so do you have anything to add
to that I think I saw you back there
don't do it okay hopefully listen to us
we just had a question about diet and
food and a bunch of other stuff that
Ryan answered masterfully and wait a
second
wait I feel like we're kind of like a
band like the minimalists you know
sometimes bands have the crowds sing
along with them so you guys know what we
in our podcast with right what do we end
up with yes
so can we end up with everyone saying
that love people and use things because
the opposite never works on three one
two three yeah yeah yeah
thank you Thank You Brooklyn thank you
so much thank you very much
[Applause]
hi Josh and Ryan this is Jennifer from
Western New York with the holidays
coming up my son is a lover of Legos but
quickly tired of them after he's built
to set I knew there had to be a better
way and so I did a google search and
quickly found two companies where you
can rent Legos or toys they will
sanitize them in between use and if you
lose a leg or two you are not penalized
this made me think about your talk that
we are moving to a culture of access so
I really wanted to share there with
every parent out there I am super
excited to take advantage of these
services and I hope other people are as
well
thank you hi Justin Ryan this is
Catherine from Austin Texas I was just
listening to the podcast were a woman
asked about how she can keep her
wardrobe minimized and I thought I would
pass along something that's worked for
me about 15 years ago I looked through
my closet I eliminated some things that
I was no longer wearing
and I decided that what I had was enough
and that I at that point started what I
called my fixed hangar role going
forward
if I wanted to bring something new into
my wardrobe I have to give up something
I think it's normal for people to want
to try new things to bring new things
into their wardrobe but that comes with
some trade-off which is you have to be
willing to let go of something that you
already have over time I realized that I
have more than enough and I started
eliminating hangers and I think that's
also part of the process that as you're
willing to reduce and get down to less
you do but I can't ever add back hangers
to my wardrobe that's my rule and that
works for me my name is Tex and I'm from
Seattle one of the minimalist secrets I
have for the holidays that I wanted to
share is the only decoration one will
ever need for the holidays is Christmas
lights no one needs a fancy tree well
decorations yard ball displays or
anything else expenses and clutter 'some
my pet peeve are those giant inflatable
motorized like balloon displays that are
really just a giant eyesore oh my god
they're so annoying anyways one set of
lights hung around a tree in the front
yard is all I ever need to put in the
Christmas spirit better yet a tradition
I've started my family is instead of
chopping down a perfectly good tree
instead go out and buy a small junior
tree for like half the price decorate it
with one set of lights and then after
the holidays Cole planted in your
backyard you will enjoy it for years and
years to come
and it would be a reminder of how great
that time in your life was Christmas
spice is all that is needed to put you
in the holiday mood everything else is
simply just tacky it also reminds me to
keep life simple and concentrate on all
the things I have to be thankful for and
it is what makes the holidays special to
me
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I bet
that you'll be fine without you
so tell your team
[Music]
you